[Music]
hey guys the 19th target and shooing
tensions have been revealed by an actor
who plays the night king the night king
has only one side a bedside all he wants
his revenge and he has the target he
wants to kill every director has a
different vision of how to play him for
dick said then and David want him to be
a cold man
some of directors want to show that
there's some human in it for the co so
played the night king is a human in the
season six episode the door where we see
children of the forest creating by
shoving a piece of dragon glass into his
chest critics said somebody made him the
night king and continues with nobody
knows who he was before a soldier or
part of nobility he never wanted to be
the night King I think he wants revenge
everybody in the story has two sides a
bad side and a good side the xix has
only one side a bad side but then we get
into real spoilers when asked what we
can expect from the night king in final
season Furtick replied with people will
see he has the target he wants to kill
and he'll find out who that test for
dick teases and just like that the
biggest mystery of games has been
revealed the night king is not coming to
destroy the human race but he doesn't
mind doing so in order to kill that
certain someone basically the night king
is coming south going into another war
with the realm of the man just because
of that particular person and that
particular someone the 19 Stargate is
most likely brain stark there's few
other popular guesses like John or Danny
but if it was John or Danny he already
had a chance to kill them in the frozen
lake battle if he could throw a spear at
the moving dragon he most certainly
could have thrown a spear at any of them
if he was truly coming after them and if
one of them was his actual target so if
it's not John or Danny for whom the
night king is coming after then it's got
to be bran Stark in season six bran
makes a risky decision to experience a
vision on his own and finds himself
looking at an army of whites and the
night king and other White Walkers at
the back bran walks closer and is
shocked to see that nothing notices his
presence brain wakes up screaming after
the nineteen certainly appears right
next to him and grabs his arm the
three-eyed Raven says that the night
King touched him which brain confirms
when a blue hand mark is seen on his
forearm the tria Raven says because of
that mark
the $99 exactly where they are the
three-eyed Raven cave got destroyed into
a raven got himself killed by the night
king but not before he spent a few good
seconds glaring at him having killed the
original thread Raven it's possible that
he is now coming after the nutria Raven
brain at the beginning of season 7 we
see bran pass the ball and then at the
end of season 7 we see the netting
attacking the wall breaching it and
passing it as well brain is currently
meaningful and as the official trailer
confirmed it the night he will be
attacking and destroying it as well just
like he has been attacking and
destroying the two previous places bran
has been before the three-eyed Raven
cave and the wall bran Stark is most
likely that particular person and
targeted the night king is coming after
for the Coe so spoiled that there will
be another stare down between Jon Snow
and the night king thinking back at
hardhome he teases there's also that
moment when Jon Snow was on the boat and
the night King looked at him and raised
his arms they're similar and even
stronger moment between Jon in the night
king this time perhaps this time it will
be more personal and this time the two
will finally fight Jon knows the night
king is coming after his little brother
but he'll firstly have to defeat him to
come anywhere close to kill brain and
the night King on the other hand doesn't
mind killing everyone to do so in
conclusion one of the biggest mysteries
of Game Jones has now been revealed the
19 Stargate is to kill us turned someone
and find out who that is in a final
season whether it's bran John Denny or
someone completely else although the
evidence point on bran stark this is
coming a bit surprising to me I did make
a theory in which i theorize have Dan in
the future night screen is the reason of
the night Kings invasion and I discussed
the popular theory of how brain might be
the reason of his march south as in the
theory brain is actually the night king
but still a revelation that the night
king is coming after one particular
person is kind of a shock and definitely
unexpected major spoiler from the cast
of Game of Thrones
let me know your thoughts about all of
this in the comment section down below
did you expect the net him to have one
particular target and person to kill and
who do you think in might be and as
always I hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did please make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and I hope to
see you in the next one peace